Tonight,...
...more than 200 years after a former colony won the right to determine its own destiny,...
...the task of perfecting our union moves forward.
It moves forward because of you.
It moves forward because you reaffirmed the spirit that has triumphed over war and depression,...
...the spirit that has lifted this country from the depths of despair...
...to the great heights of hope,...
...the belief that while each of us will pursue our own individual dreams,...
...we are an American family and we rise or fall together as one nation and as one people.
Tonight, in this election,...
...you, the American people, reminded us that while our road has been hard,...
...while our journey has been long, we have picked ourselves up, we have fought our way back...
...and we know in our hearts...
...that for the United States of America the best is yet to come.